MALE SPEAKER: I want to
introduce Chef Charles Phan
from the famed restaurant,
The Slanted Door.
I remember I've been going to
this restaurant since '95, so
it's a real pleasure
to have him here.
He's a real San Francisco
success story.
How many restaurants do you have
now, and what's on the
horizon for you?
CHARLES PHAN: We actually
have five.
We had six, but we're
down to five.
I guess always my favorite one,
the new one, we're doing
a Bourbon and Creole concept.
We haven't figured
out a name yet.
Some working title like
[? Bird Bar ?]
or Horseshoes.
The idea is just to have these
vintage out of production
Bourbon that doesn't
exist anymore.
Unfortunately, the whole
industry is just dying,
because all these old little
distilleries that made some
great bourbon-- it takes
like 20 years to age--
and so we want to showcase
that, and
Creole and fried chicken.
So that's coming up.
MALE SPEAKER: And I was just
hearing you talk about, you
actually won some awards
for your mixology.
Do you mind talking about
that a little bit?
CHARLES PHAN: Crazy enough, our
family, and not just the
immediate family--
we started the company
17 years ago.
And the head manager's been
with me 15 or more.
So about 20 years ago, we
started serving cocktail.
We were really the first local
San Francisco restaurant to do
mixology, and doing things
naturally and organic product.
Remember, the first cocktail we
made was like a margarita.
I didn't want to use these
plastic lines that comes in a
little plastic ball,
and Rosa mix.
And this year, at the Tales
of the Cocktail, this is a
convention for all the
cocktail folks.
And I think regular folks
can go sign up.
It's a week long of drinking and
research in New Orleans,
and they give out awards.
It was for nomination, and we
won the category of best
restaurant bar.
And they have, I think, regular
bar, hotel bar,
restaurant bar.
And it was really amazing that
the colleague of the cocktail
world think we make
the best cocktail.
Actually, there was competition
from London, also.
A European was also in the
mix for this award.
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
that your restaurant, there's
a real family atmosphere
involved.
You actually have some real
family members that work for
you, don't you?
CHARLES PHAN: Yeah, I've
got 22 relatives.
I don't have a choice in that.
I have to hire them, because
my mom says so, and I can't
really fire them.
I guess I can fire them if they
do something illegal.
Like, hitting somebody,
that would be illegal.
Well, the family
aspect of it--
I came and I wanted to do
classic Vietnamese food with
organic ingredients.
And I have a background in
architecture, so I want to do
modern design, and I didn't want
to have a restaurant with
bamboo and Buddha and
stuff like that.
Not that that's bad, but that's
just not my thing.
And I was just sick and tired
of the stereotyping.
I didn't want to do that.
But once we started doing it,
and I needed help on the wine,
and we have a wine director
for 14 years, and then he
finally quit and went to
farming, we were the first
company in San Francisco
to do Riesling.
And no one would do in Riesling,
and we were getting
a lot of flack for that.
But it would really
go with our food.
Napa Valley was kind of angry
that we don't use them, but it
just was hard, because the
alcohol content would make the
Vietnamese food taste bad, and
make the wine taste bad.
But now Napa Valley is growing a
lot of lower-alcohol stuff--
under 14%, and that worked
with our food.
Same thing with our cocktails.
So we apply the same methodology
to everything we
do, from composting--
we were the first company
composting
with the garbage company.
They were a guinea
pig 17 years ago.
And San Francisco developed a
whole system of composting
that was unlike any other
place, because
of the Kyoto summit.
They wanted to reduce their
waste by 50%, I can't
remember, a couple years ago.
And we were the first company.
Part of the guinea pig.
And literally, today, we produce
only 16% waste of all
our facilities.
Everything gets composted.
The oil gets recycled.
In fact, there's people who come
and pick it up, take the
used oil that we take, and go
make something with it, which
I'm not allowed to say.
But they pick up my oil, so it
doesn't go into a landfill or
the sewage system.
The cocktail, same thing.
I just wanted to
make it simple.
Food with a story,
have a history.
So my philosophy behind all
this, and hence the book, is
to bring a little piece of
Vietnam to here, but using
local ingredients, and using
local sensibility.
What I mean by that is I can't
really cook beef well done.
Most folks here don't
like shoe leather.
But in Vietnam, or other parts
of the country, they might
like their meat cooked
a little bit more.
But I remember eating
[INAUDIBLE]
beef-- a dish that's very
popular at Slanted Door--
in a hotel in 1992, and they
were using flank steak,
smaller cut.
And I thought the flavor was
great, but I thought the beef
was a little chewy.
Then, opening year, at the
time there was a lot of
airline fillet, and you used
to be able to get whole
medallion fillet at United first
class, and everybody was
doing that back then still.
So they had these tails that
no one wants, and it was
really cheap.
And I got them, and I cut them
into little pieces, and I was
serving fillet.
And I sort of created that
dish using fillet.
And today, the airline industry
stopped serving
fillet, and we buy
a grass fed.
We continue to improve using a
grass fed beef fillet, and
we're using an organic
watercress for the bedding.
So the recipe is traditional,
but just the
way we present it.
So I don't try to really
mess with the food.
I mean, a lot of the kitchen
folks like to play around with
[INAUDIBLE]
and form and all that, but
sometimes I don't let that get
in the way, because I think our
mission is always, bring a
little story about the food, and
tell you, this is how the
Vietnamese are doing it.
This is the Vietnamese
aesthetic.
Whether you like it or
not is not my issue.
It's for me to present it.
Obviously if you don't
like it too much,
I'll go out of business.
So I have to make food that
people like to eat, but we
always want to challenge that.
And I cooked dinner the other
night at [? Chez Panis ?] and
one of the courses we wanted
to do was sardine clay pot
with cherry tomato.
And a few people, my chefs say,
wow, this is so fancy.
You should fillet it.
And I say, no, in Vietnam,
we don't fillet anything.
That's just not how
it happens.
In fact, we like to
suck on the bone.
So for me, I just don't
want to temper that.
And we put it in a beautiful
crockery with
fine linen and China.
It doesn't look like
Vietnam at all.
But the bowl looks like
Vietnam, you know?
For me to present that.
If you don't want to buy it--
And I did, in fact, that dish
has struck out a few times at
Slanted Door, because no one
bought it in the first year.
MALE SPEAKER: So is there a
particular dish that you've
had since you started
your restaurant
that's on the menu today?
CHARLES PHAN: There's
quite a bit of them.
The dish that kind of gave me
the impetus to start the
restaurant was the
spring roll.
My mom, it was her--
Just a little background.
I went to school--
I came to San Francisco when I
was in eighth grade in 1978.
We left Vietnam in '75.
I went to junior high.
I went to Mission High.
I really wanted to
be a potter.
Is that Mission High?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES PHAN: Oh, OK.
Cool.
And I wanted to be a potter, and
my dad wanted me to be an
engineer and a doctor
and stuff like that.
And I ended up getting
into Cal.
I got into Cooper Union, but
ended up going to Cal to do
architecture so he'd get off my
back of yelling at me for
doing art school.
But during that time, I got a
job bussing tables in '78.
He was a janitor.
And I really saw the
food business
from the service side.
And I went to school not knowing
that I wanted to cook.
And I guess I like to cook,
and I cook a lot at home.
My folks had two jobs.
Then I left school, didn't
finish school, and ended up
running my folks' garment
business.
And I actually had a clothing
store and tried to design
clothes, but that didn't
go too well.
It wasn't really my thing.
I was just trying to be
entrepreneurial like my folks.
They were doing stuff they'd
never done before.
Then that I went belly up,
and lost a lot of money.
It was during the savings
and loan debacle.
People filed Chapter 11,
we lost a lot of money.
And then I actually got into
software, and selling software
for the SGI.
And running around down here
setting up dealers, and in
post production, we were trying
to go against the
[INAUDIBLE] the clientele
and so on using--
But back then, I think it cost
$50,000 to get 30 seconds into
the computer of video.
And that company went belly up,
and that's when I had a
little money from my job and
started Slanted Door in 1994.
It took me a year to build it.
I always had this idea my head
to build Slanted Door in this
small little place with a modern
design and the food,
but I never lost track that,
because of [? Chez Panis ?]
in Berkeley, I always wanted
some really simple.
But my thing is always have a
history and story with food.
So when I'm learning Moroccan
and Japanese, I like to go to
the source, learn how the
flavor, and just kind of come
back and create the craft.
Anyway, over the year, people
asked me [INAUDIBLE]
book, and--
MALE SPEAKER: That was
my next question.
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, never
graduated college.
That's why.
I don't like to do homework.
And there's a reason why I never
graduated from college,
and it's just, I never finished
my English [? 180 ?]
that I had to turn
in my paper.
But more seriously, I didn't
think I had enough stuff.
I think you've got to have
enough things to
say to write a book.
But finally, after about two
years ago, my agent convinced
me to send out a proposal.
And originally, everybody wanted
a Slanted Door cookbook
and recipes.
I didn't think that cool.
I always thought it looked like
a high school yearbook,
and a couple years later,
you go back, and it's
like, who's that guy?
You know?
I really wanted to do a book
that showed people how to
cook, and more important,
to give you
the Vietnamese aesthetic.
And the idea is to really want
you to understand not only
just how to cook, but how to you
eat this food, and why the
Vietnamese eat it this way.
There's a reason for it, and
sometimes I don't know what
the reason, but this
is how they eat it.
If they eat a bowl of pho, they
would put them in one
thing at a time.
They don't put the whole
thing together.
And the technique part, I see
a lot of people that don't
understand the stir fry,
the steam technique.
They just kind of blindly
put the stuff together.
So the whole impetus of the book
was like, OK, these are
the principles of stir fry, and
these are the principles
of grill, and these are
the dos and don'ts.
And if you understand that, it's
going to make your life a
lot easier how to cook
this stuff, because
this stuff is not--
in fact, you shouldn't
follow the recipe.
I think you should understand
why we do what we do, why we
brown the beef first, or steam
the broccoli first before we
brown the beef.
Because there's a
reason for it.
If you do beef and broccoli
stir fry, the broccoli is
going to be hard, and the beef,
you want medium rare.
You can't just throw everything
in like a salad
bowl with a big flame underneath
and toss it, hoping
that all the stuff
is going to cook.
So you've got to steam your
vegetable first, pull it out,
brown your meat, make
your sauce,
and assemble it together.
But most people just kind of
picture the word stir fry, and
just tossing.
And same with grilling.
Most people just go out and buy
an expensive gas grill,
because they see it
at Home Depot, and
they dream about it.
I hate those things.
Those are the worst thing.
I think a great charcoal grill,
if you know how to
harness it and cook [INAUDIBLE]
those, it's just
one of the biggest joys of
cooking is to really feel like
you can do this in a campsite.
And there's just basic
rules that you know.
It takes 30 minutes to
start your fire.
Like all this-- once you're
comfortable with that, it's so
easy to come home,
start that fire.
You don't buy briquettes,
because I
don't know what's inside.
And with the charcoal, there's
a lot of air-- if you stack
up, it's got a lot of air, so
when you light it, it catches
on fire faster.
Briquettes are just these little
square things the rest
of the world does not use.
Only in America.
MALE SPEAKER: Is there a
particular recipe in the book
that you're really proud of, or
you think everyone should
go home and make?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, no, no, I
think you should just pick
some that [INAUDIBLE]
like a technique, and
focus on that.
There's some stuff that
will take you three or
four days to do.
It's really hard.
Like making the rice paper skin,
you actually have to go
to Home Depot first to buy,
like, making the tin, and it's
just amazing.
It's called [? bankun. ?]
I made this.
I was invited to cook
at The Master.
This is in Carmel.
They don't do that now.
It's called Pebble Beach
Food and Wine.
And they invite people all
over the world, France,
Germany, to cook them
super expensive.
It was my first trip going
down there, and we were
fighting over the
kitchen space.
And me and this chef--
she's since retired--
this 60 year old lady were
relegated to the pastry
department with a little
Bunsen burner.
And we made this steam thing.
Basically, you make it a ring,
you get this piece of nylon
fabric, like a parachute
fabric.
You stretch it with a hose
clamp, then you make this
batter and you pour it, and then
you steam it, you peel
out with two stick, and
you make this roll.
And when we did that, the entire
kitchen stopped and all
surrounded us.
And it was one of the coolest
moments in my cooking career
to see all these fancy three
star, five star, whatever
Michelin restaurant chefs who
stop everything and see this
thing with a little
Bunsen burner.
And she would just gracefully
wrap this thing.
It's in the book.
It's going to take
you three days.
But it's just supple, and it's
just amazing, and it makes me
so happy to have this little
peasant food competing with
the caviar, the foie gras,
the five star restaurant.
And still, as long as she's
sitting there, beautiful
setting, and nice linen, and
great food, it really doesn't
matter where it comes from.
MALE SPEAKER: So when was the
last time when you were back
in Vietnam, and can you share
anything from your trip there?
CHARLES PHAN: Yeah.
The book was shot in Vietnam.
When I go to Vietnam, it's
always a little blurry.
Vietnam's amazing,
especially today.
The first year I went
back was 1992.
I left '75, '92, the
smell and sound--
the sad thing is, Vietnam
had just sat
dormant for a long time.
In fact, the year Bill Clinton
came to my restaurant in 2000,
in April, and June he went back
and opened up Vietnam.
That's the year my relatives
started seeing changes,
started making money.
Prior to that, they were
pretty much living off
probably $40 a month.
They were in poverty.
It was horrible.
And Vietnam was [INAUDIBLE].
My wife's in Bangkok, so I've
been going to Bangkok for the
last 17, 18 years, and you
really see the difference
between the development.
And Vietnam's still trying
to catch up.
Fortunately, they really are
learning how to protect the
environment.
So there are lot
of bans on teak
export, antiquity exports.
But at the same time, they're
like everybody else.
They try to get their Mercedes,
and they try to live
a good life.
And it's changing a lot, so I do
encourage you to go sooner
rather than later.
But it's a lot easier today,
because back in '92, there
were hardly any restaurants,
because people are poor.
I think food follows money.
When there's a lot of money,
there's a lot of good food.
And there's an amazing expat
community there today compared
to 10 years ago.
And you find a couple of those
guys, they'll tell
you where to eat.
I'm on the board called One
Vietnam dot [INAUDIBLE]..
I think.
It's sort of like a place where
people can donate money
back to Vietnam.
That's another source.
You can kind of look for a
blog and story, because
unfortunately, we don't have
Yellow Pages or Yelp or all
this extensive review
on restaurants.
Like here, we can look at.
Over there, still, a restaurant
can be gone in six
months, so you kind of rely on
local experts who live there.
My suggestion is do go.
Try and eat not a whole lot of
raw things, and bring your
Pepto Bismol and
diarrhea pill.
You're going to get sick, not
because it's got a lot of
disease, but it's because
you're overeating.
If you're like me, when I
travel, I eat six meals a day.
So therefore, hence,
I get sick.
And I'm not even tell you how
many rounds of drink I have in
between that.
So by nature, you're
going to get sick,
because you eat so much.
But secondly, try to
eat something warm.
My first place usually
is the wet market.
The wet market's amazing,
and I wish that we
understand that more.
In this country, we've tried to
build more farmers market.
Over there, they're trying
to shut it down.
They want Safeway.
And it's just a crazy circle.
The production chain from farm
to table is very short.
They have a lot of
little farms.
A little pig rides on
a scooter, goes to a
slaughterhouse, and gets cut
up and goes to the market.
If you go to these markets,
you actually don't see any
refrigeration.
It looks a little scary, but if
you smell it, if you open
your nose, you notice there's
nothing rotten, which means
they killed it in the morning,
and they eat it that day.
And they don't have tags that
say expire by October 15th.
There's no expiration date.
You literally smell it, and if
you can't figure out if it's
rotten, then you shouldn't
be cooking it anyway.
So unfortunately, they try to
become us, and we try to
become them.
It's just kind of sad.
And in Hong Kong, it's
the same way.
And they don't really have,
unfortunately, a lot of
practices of protecting the
fisheries and so on, but
still, they don't have radar
yet to go out and fish mass
amounts of fish.
But they start getting to.
In fact, a lot of tuna
is coming out
of the Vietnam water.
In fact, a lot of places--
a friend of mine, Paul
[? Bukalole ?]
in Vegas, amazing restaurant at
the Wynn, and he gets fish
from mostly Italy.
And most of his fish actually
come from Libyan water.
And when Libya went to war, he
couldn't have any fish to
sell, because a lot of
these places are just
getting fished out.
And some of the places, actually
war torn, nobody's
fishing there yet.
In fact, the joke is,
fishes in Libya
actually have beards--
like, long beards, because
they're so old.
So anyway, Vietnam is a really
amazing place to visit.
And you go to the market,
there's a lot of food there.
You can eat the hot food, and
hot food, usually, you're
fairly clean.
And just use your judgment.
And sometimes you can look at
the back of the stand, if they
have running water or not, if
they're just carrying water to
wash their bowl, stuff
like that.
And the market is just like
a cool place to visit.
But today, there's so many
restaurants, I can't tell you.
It's probably 100 times more
compared to 10 years ago, when
I ate in Vietnam.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So with the architectural
background, how much of an
influence do you have on your
restaurant designs, and what
do you focus on?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, fortunately,
I meet my dear
friend, now my close friend Ole
Lundberg, Lundberg Design
in 2004 when I moved to
the ferry building.
He's in the book.
There's actually a couple
photographs.
A lot of the book was shot in
his outdoor kitchen in his
weekend home in Sonoma Coast.
So Ole, it's a funny thing.
When everybody finds out that I
was going to the [INAUDIBLE]
everybody sent a portfolio,
and they say,
you should hire us.
In fact, some architects say,
I've eaten at your restaurant
for years, and they would tear
out the portfolio with a
fusion restaurant, with a Buddha
head, and they circle
it and they say, look, I
do Buddha restaurants.
And no one really
gets who I am.
And Ole, I went in there, and
he had a big old shop.
In fact, I was on my way to
the dump in Carhartt and
hoodie and his receptionist
said, you know we're an
architectural firm, right?
We're not a contractor.
He was going to throw me out.
But anyway, we met, and I asked
him how you would do my
restaurant.
He said, well, you take a really
simple thing, and you
make it really beautiful.
I'm going to do the same, so I'm
not going to give you fake
Formica, and it's really about
the craft and building.
So if you go to the Slanted
Door today, everything is
built by his shop--
like, the reception desk,
even the table
bases, the light fixture.
It's about the craft of
building, through that, the
design, obviously.
And that restaurant is 10 years
old, it's getting like
1,000 people through it, and
it's holding out pretty well.
And he and I have become
essentially drinking buddies,
and that's why we're building
this bourbon bar.
In fact, there was like 400
bottles in this office right
now because we got on eBay and
collected all these vintage.
We couldn't find them.
Some of these do not exist at
all, and crazy enough, last
week, eBay shut down the whole
alcohol sales division, so we
just got it in the
nick of time.
So we got these amazing bourbon,
interesting bourbon
from the last 40 years.
And the idea with this bar is
an American whiskey bar.
We don't have any scotch, and
the whole idea is just
preserving this culture that
is dying by the day.
I mean, when I first opened
bar 10 years ago, we were
buying this one company called
[INAUDIBLE], and no
one knows about it.
In fact, you get on eBay today,
it's running at $250 to
$400 a bottle.
And we used to buy so much,
that was our well bourbon.
It's crazy.
And we used to get
our own barrels.
And about a year ago, they cut
us off, because it was sold to
a bigger company.
And it's kind of a bummer,
because I'm no longer dealing
with the family, and the
demand is so high.
So what happened in bourbon
is, you age it.
You could have 100,
200 barrels,
and they're all different.
They're put in these what's
called rick houses, and
they're not temperature
controlled.
In fact, the whole idea
is just let mother
nature do its thing.
And the upper level is hotter,
so the alcohol will go in and
out of the charcoal char wood,
and it absorbs some of the
brown flavor.
And each barrel tastes
a little different.
We used to get to pick our own
barrel, but most manufacturers
don't like to do that.
They like to mix all the 12
year olds, mix it all and
bottle it so they have
a consistent product.
And we used to get
our own barrel.
It's Danny Meyer and myself were
the only two people, and
Danny was an amazing
restaurateur in New York City,
and he's from St. Louis.
And unfortunately, all this
thing is gone, the [INAUDIBLE]
destroyed, it's all gobbled
up by big conglomerates.
So we try to save
some of these--
the stuff we know is good that
we're putting on the list.
So this is sort of like
a special place to
buy a shot of bourbon.
MALE SPEAKER: So being a big
restaurateur now, what have
some of your challenges been,
scaling up your operation?
And also, what's new on the
horizon other than your
bourbon bar?
CHARLES PHAN: It's always
a challenge.
I think just people.
My chef Justine, she
came to me like six
months after I opened.
We used to fight so crazy
[INAUDIBLE] certain day, I
don't want to go to work,
because either I'll kill her
or I'll fire her.
One or the other.
But now we're like the left
hand and the right hand.
And just managing that
relationship, because now
she's got kids, and she's got to
move on, because, I mean, I
used to be on the line every
night, and I have kids, and I
can't do that anymore,
so she took over.
And now she has kids,
she can't do that.
And finding the next generation
constantly doing that.
How do you keep doing the same
thing and get people inspired?
That's kind of tough, because
I'm bored out of my mind
making spring rolls and shaking
beef, but at the same
time, it's my rent money, so
I kind of have to do it.
But we always try to find
a way to do it.
But always creating these new
projects, it really inspires
the whole team.
The constant struggle is always
finding ingredients.
We'll find a chicken farmer.
Like, commodity chicken is about
$1.10, $1.20 a pound,
sometimes goes down
to $0.80 a pound.
These are like the Tysons
of the world.
But organic chicken's $4.00 a
pound, and they still go out
of business.
At $4.00 a pound, they
can't make it.
And every year, we see them go
out of business, and our
demand never goes lower.
We just get higher and higher
on these demands.
How you do that?
So often, it's supplied by
multiple farms, and sometimes
we have to pay them more.
And balancing between value to
our customer and charging the
right price.
But often, the number
doesn't lie.
Sometimes you just got
to charge a lot.
And in hoping that, OK, maybe
you shouldn't eat
chicken every day.
Maybe it should be a little
bit more special.
Maybe it's all wrong that
chicken is $1.60 a pound.
In Vietnam, when I was growing
up, you get it once a month.
You go kill the chicken.
It's a big deal.
Here, you can get chicken three
meals a day, breakfast,
lunch, and dinner, and
seven days a week.
And I think we've got to realign
what's important and
not always say it's
got to be cheap.
MALE SPEAKER: So I just have a
quick question, then I'll open
it up to the audience.
What do you think the kitchen
of the future looks like?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, they go
through these fads, right?
And in the '80s, when I was
busing tables in '78, '79,
this [? called ?] nouvelle
cuisine, like, they gave you
almost like the Google logo--
three colors and three pieces
about that long.
And then afterwards, you've got
to go to Chinatown and get
full, because there's no
food on those plate.
And that was the '80s, right?
And now, for a long time,
[INAUDIBLE] this whole
[INAUDIBLE].
But what I see lately is that
people are starting to get
fatigue of sitting through three
hour long meals, these
fancy meals.
They still want good food, but
they just want it a little bit
more casual.
They can just get in and out
and not have a [INAUDIBLE]
come and talk to you,
and on and on.
I mean, there are always going
to be fancy restaurants, but I
think that people are super
educated now, more than ever.
When I first opened, I served
maybe five whole fish the
entire night.
Busy restaurant, 300 customers,
and three of them
will come back.
People were upset they
saw the head.
Today, I serve 30, 28 fish a
night, and there has not been
a fish coming back within
the last seven years.
And with the Food Network, and
all this stuff, people are
just a lot more educated
about what food.
And so I don't even
try to guess what
people like or not like.
I just put it out there.
If it works, it works.
If it doesn't, I just
pull it back.
At this point, at some point,
you just don't try to guess.
But because I come from this
angle of classic Vietnamese
food, so I'm very confident
in the food I put out.
What they don't like, then we
can always adjust and not
continue serving the food.
But product ingredients are so
important, and also not eating
extinct fish like Chilean
sea bass.
In fact, there's a
recipe in there.
It was the first fish.
I used to blow through about
50 pounds of flesh--
just meat--
a day at the original Slanted
Door, and they found out this
fish doesn't reproduce until
they're 40 years old.
And in fact, today, Whole Foods
started saying it's OK,
but I don't believe it.
So I don't eat Chilean sea
bass, but that is the
fish for that dish.
Steamed.
I use the black bass now, but
that fish is so much oil with
three mushroom steam.
It's just sublime.
You just can't eat it,
unfortunately.
And we try to substitute
other things.
Unfortunately, I have to
admit that nothing even
compares to that fish.
And crazy enough, that fish,
the hotel people loved it,
because you can stick in
that box for two hours
and it never dies.
And this is one of those fish
that will make you look good,
even if you can't cook.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So I'd like to open
up to questions.
You mind stepping up to the
microphone, please?
AUDIENCE: The French left the
footprint on the colonial
architecture of Vietnam.
Could you talk about how they
also left the footprint on the
cooking of Vietnam?
Are there any dishes which
really combine the best of
French classical cooking
with Vietnamese?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, everybody
would say that the Vietnamese
sandwich, the French
left there.
But I like to say that we took
a French baguette and we made
it 100 times better.
Definitely, the French had.
The Chinese were in there much
longer, and the dishes like
the braised short ribs, it
will be a very minute
difference.
Like, we don't have ovens.
We don't roast the bone.
That's why the beef noodle
soup, I blanch it in hot
water, and that's why I want
to explain all this to you.
Because French classic stock
making, you blanch the bone,
you coagulate the blood.
So you simmer it, the blood
doesn't break into little
microscopic and make
your soup cloudy.
And Vietnam, we don't
have ovens, and we
have very simple tools.
And you blanch it in hot water,
you wash out all the
gunk, it sucks the blood out
inside the bone, that bandsaws
all the crud.
So in this case, we don't have
stock, so we use water to do
the short ribs.
And it's just much lighter.
And we don't have the
pavanse herb.
We use lemon grass and ginger
and fish sauce.
So it's a little different
version.
Then we try to do casserole,
like French food, and we do a
horrible job at it, so
it's not in the book.
AUDIENCE: So you were talking
about how customers are no
longer sending back whole
fish because they
don't like the head.
I'm imagining that authentic
Vietnamese peasant cuisine
probably still has some features
that Westerners
wouldn't be happy with.
If you're a peasant cook,
you don't waste
any part of the animal.
Chicken feet kind of
things, intestines.
Are you planning to
introduce more
adventurous Vietnamese food?
CHARLES PHAN: I try.
I did a [? Wu-Hing ?]
general [? store, ?] which is
Chinese braised pork knuckle.
It's not a big seller.
In fact, there's pork
knuckle soup.
One of the cleanest broths.
Everybody knows beef and
chicken, but a pork knuckle
soup in Vietnam is
just amazing.
I mean, I love chewing on
the knuckle afterward.
In fact, if you're going
to buy pig feet, you
want to buy the front.
The back's a lot tougher,
because the back needs to kick
more, so you buy
the front feet.
And we are that actually anal
about which part of
the animal we eat.
The tripe and that stuff, yeah,
I always try to convert
people to eat that weird stuff,
but even my own family,
my kids and my wife, and
they don't buy it.
But I think eventually,
there's always
people that do it.
Chris Constantino opened a
restaurant, nothing but offal
in San Francisco.
But things like shrimp paste,
and if you don't talk about
it, people don't get
freaked out.
I mean, we do a fish called
[? jakaten lung. ?]
It's a dish out of Hanoi that
is named after the street.
I mean, it's named after
the restaurant.
They only have one dish, and the
only thing you choose is
Heineken or soda or tea.
That's your choice of menu.
You go there, because they
give you only one dish.
And the sauce is made out of
this ground up anchovy sauce
with pineapple, and it's
one of the most
amazing balanced sauce.
But if I just gave you the
straight up anchovy, it just
smells like sewage.
It smells pretty bad.
Same thing with stinky tofu, but
sometime, somehow, people
just kind of like that smell.
So I can't explain it.
But is it going to change
drastically?
No.
Probably a very small
population.
We'll probably have better bet
in San Francisco than the
middle of the country.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, going back to
the discussion about fish, do
you see the future of this sort
of sustainable cooking as
figuring out direct replacements
for each of these
fish, or do you think that we
need to grow the recipes for
the more sustainable fish
like sardines and those?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, a
recipe is a recipe.
If it doesn't work-- like, this
recipe is pretty simple.
What's happening today is, like,
the east coast started
learning how to manage their
fishery much better than the
west coast.
That's why last year they found
out all the crab's not
happening, or the salmon
is not happening.
So they were kind of slow
to catch up with that.
But I can tell you the success
stories, like the black bass
out in Maryland, the scallop.
In the '70s, it got so
bad that scallop
was going to be extinct.
And no one even knows this.
By the way, if you eat
great scallop, fresh
scallop, it's amazing.
And unfortunately, a lot of
scallops are covered in this
product called TSP.
They preserve it, and they break
down super fast so that
you have the word day boat
scallop because the last day,
whatever the last batch is, they
don't cover this stuff.
It's not waterlogged,
so they charge more
for day boat scallop.
We need to start eating
farm raised fish.
We just got to eat
the right one.
For a long time, salmon gave a
really bad rap on these closed
containers, all these
antibiotics were put in there,
food coloring to make their--
you know?
I think there's a book out
called "The Four Fish," and it
talks a lot about how
to manage all this.
In fact, the author talks about,
we don't go out and
shoot a buffalo and put
it in Costco, right?
But we do that with tuna.
And essentially, that's
what we're doing.
We shoot this wild animal, big,
and we put inside this
mass scale, and we eat
it like we just chuck
it out of some factory.
So I think all of us in the
community, from chef to
consumer, we've just got to make
sure that we don't eat
the fish that we can't eat.
And the best place is
really the Monterey
Bay Aquarium chart.
They do a very abbreviated
version, just
kind of color coded.
But for us we go
a level deeper.
And sometimes, for instance,
we'll use certain cod from the
east coast, if they align
cod by the right family.
And there's a balance, also,
keeping these communities
alive up in the Northeast.
Like, you can't just say, well,
you can't fish anymore.
I mean, sure, you can
say that, because
you've got a day job.
They don't.
So it's just, if everybody's on
top of it, the marketplace
will dictate.
If you go to a wedding,
you say, I'm not
eating Chilean sea bass.
So hopefully, enough people do
it, I guarantee you, even big
hotels will stop using it.
Because a lot of those guys,
they just worry about their
job, and they don't care
about anything else.
And they serve this stuff, and
we've got to put pressure on
them not to do this stuff,
because it's sad.
Lobster is another great story
how it's abundant now, the way
they don't let you take
female lobster.
AUDIENCE: You talked about how
you've gone back to Vietnam
and all that.
I'm not sure how often.
But each time you do, have you
seen them progress from when
they first opened to all the
progress they've made, they've
become a lot more metropolitan
and all that.
Have you seen their food change
a lot between when you
left in '75 and what they
serve now, what's become
mainstream now?
And have you gotten any
inspirations from that for
your own food?
CHARLES PHAN: Vietnam
was very closed off.
When I was growing up, you only
learned Vietnamese food.
You might get influence, let's
say, from a northern cook, or
a Hue, which is a
central region.
But today, there's sushi,
there's tapas, there's French
restaurants.
And pretty soon,
I think they're
going to get Food Network.
So they can't help themselves,
except to-- when you give a
cook something, they're
going to cook.
They're not going to say, it's
Japanese, I don't do it.
They want everything you want.
And you can see how
it affects it.
But at the same time, there's
a lot of local restaurants
that are getting very busy,
because the local economy is
doing well.
And they're just exploiting the
bounty of what they can
catch, and sometimes, to their
fault, they're eating a little
lobster they shouldn't
be eating.
And hopefully, the country is
smart enough to start telling
people not to catch it.
But it's pretty hard.
They're not wealthy, so they
don't have government money to
regulate catching these
little baby lobsters.
It's going back to the
lobster story.
You've got to be seven inches
from the back of
the head to the tail.
That's the only size
you have to catch.
If it has eggs, then you have to
put it back, and you put a
notch in its tail.
It's called the V notch, and it
pretty much guarantees that
lobster lives forever, because
even if you pick them up a
second time around without
eggs, you see a V notch,
you've got to put it back.
And in fact, about four or five
years ago, Massachusetts
decided to go along with
everybody else, because the
eastern seaboard, they
go in circles.
The lobsters migrate
in circles.
So in Boston, Massachusetts,
you weren't
going along with Maine.
And finally, they did it, and
lobster prices have been
stable, they got more than ever,
and in fact, every two
licenses has to retire before
one could be issued.
And they have less people
fishing, they get more product
than ever, and I do recommend
eating lobster in New England.
I don't know why it
tastes better.
And I ship them here literally
from a friend of mine's boat,
and it doesn't taste the same.
I think the stress makes
them taste bad.
And something about boiling
in the local water.
It's just amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: So one more
quick question.
You said that in addition to the
Monterey Bay Sea Aquarium
guide, you go one
step further.
How do you do that?
Do you work with local
fishermen?
CHARLES PHAN: Well, there's
a guy, Paul Johnson, who
[? wrote ?]
Monterey Fish.
He's got a book out.
There's only a few
guys I trust.
And also, when you travel, like
today, all our shrimp is
from Louisiana.
We don't buy frozen shrimp
anymore from Asia.
It took me a long time.
Finally, Jimmy [? Gower ?]
started to figure out how to get
this shrimp to fly standby
with Southwest.
And I'm not kidding.
And literally, he picks them
up, covers them in ice, and
it's not even sorted.
And it's so fresh, because
shrimp comes
in different sizes.
They're by catch, they sort it,
and they cut the head off.
It's all this labor.
Frozen shrimp, Thailand, it's
about $6.00, $7.00 a pound,
and fresh, wild shrimp, it's
about, with head, which means
you've got to have some
waste there, it's
about $14, $16 a pound.
And today, I think we only use
less than 15% from wild
shrimp, and the 85% come from
frozen shrimp from Asia or
across the globe.
I don't have time to find out
what's happening in Asia, and
even Monterey doesn't know
what they do over there.
So I was happy to work with
Jimmy and have all wild shrimp
inside our restaurant.
And the head breaks the
shrimp down very fast.
That's why when you buy shrimp,
usually it doesn't
come with the head, because
there's something chemical
that makes them all measly.
And the head is the
best flavor.
You cut the head, and even if
you don't eat it, the juices
coming out, like the
caramelized shrimp
dish, it's a must.
And even whole food, you buy
frozen one, it's not the best,
but it's still better
anything.
And don't be afraid
to use that.
MALE SPEAKER: Charles will be
up here to sign your book.
Thank you very much.